حياتهم مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
واليوم
رحله نبقى فيها باندونيسيا المليئه بعادات
وتقاليد لقبائل متنوعه وزاخره بالتعدد
عوالم اندونيسيا حافله بالمغامرات
والمفاجات تحديدا اليوم سنتعرف على واحده
من اكثر القبائل ادهشن قبيله تدانغ اللي
تعتبر تقاليد الزواج فيها من اغرب طقوس
الزواج حول العالم
الاندلسيه بحضر دخول المرحاض على
المتزوجين حديثا لمده ثلاثه ايام بعد
زفافهم وبيتم ابقاء العروسين تحت حراسه
مشدده خشيه مخالفه القواعد والقوانين
ومراقبه منعهم من فول المرحله
سبب العاده الغريبه دي وحرصهم عليها هو
اعتقاد الراسخ بانه كسر هذه القاعده قد
يجلب الفال السيء للزوجين زي الخيانه
الزوجيه او موت احد اطفالهم او حتى عدم
انجابهم او عدم استمرار حياتهم في هدوء
واستقرار وسلام
عشان كده بتتم مراقبه الزوجين من قبل
الاقارب والجيران او الاصدقاء المقربين
ولا يسمح لهم بعد الزواج مباشره لمده
ثلاثه ايام الا بكميات قليله جدا من
الطعام والشراب تكاتك فيهم على البقاء
احياء وبعد مرور ثلاثه ايام بيتم
الاستحمام ويسمح لهم باستخدام المرحاض
وحريه الحركه وقتها بتتم مباركتهم
والاعتراف بقدسيه زوجتهم والاطمئنان لانها
تكون حياه سعيده وهادئه ومطمئنه ومستقرره
من المعتقدات الغريبه والشائعه عند افراد
قبيله داون ان الازواج اللي بيجتازوا
التجربه دي بنجاح وبيخوض التحدي وحدهم هم
القادرين على الحصول على زواج دائم وطويل
الامد او حياه مستقره اما اللي بيفشلوا
بيكون عندهم حظ سيء في زواجهم او بتطرق
عليهم مفاجات سيئه قد تهدد استقرار وتهدد
حياتهم الهادئه
قبيله دي دونج من اغرب واعجب القبائل
بتعيش في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من
بارنيو بالقرب من الحدود بين اندونيسيا
وماليزيا اعداد بتقدر بالالاف ما في
احصائيه محدده عن ارقام لانه الزيارات
لتلك المناطق محدده جدا وقد لا يسمح لاي
احد بالدخول الى هذا العالم الا من خلال
اذن خاص من كبارات القبيله اللي قد يسمح
وياذن بالدخول الى عالم وقد يرفضوا بحسب
الظروف المجتمعيه المحيطه بهذا العالم
الحياه داخل المجتمع قبيله التيدونج
بتعتمد على المشاركه بين الرجال والنساء
سواء في الزراعه او في الصيد او حتى في
تقاسم المهام اليوميه داخل الاسره بتقوم
المراه بتربيه الابناء وبتحمل الاعباء
المنزليه المختلفه ولكن الرجل يشارك
بفعاليه في تفاصيل مختلفه في الطبخ في
تهيئه الابناء في التعامل معاهم وفي
التربيه
الصيد هو المهمه الرئيسيه للرجال رجال
مشهورين في الصيد
وبيمارسوا الصيد في اوقات مختلفه
وبيحتفل عند حصولهم على صيد ثمين وبتتجمع
كل افراد القبيله للاحتفاء بهذه المناسبه
الرجال ايضا بيقوم برعايه الحيوانات التي
يعتبروها صديقه لهم وبتشاركم تفاصيل
حياتهم وبيئته
سيدان شعب هادئ الطباع ومسالم لكنه يفضل
الانعزال عن العالم الخارجي الى حد كبير
لاعتقاد ان الاحتكاك قد ياتي بنذير شؤم
على علم وقد يهدد هدوء او قد يكنس هويه
الخاصه بهم اللي هم بيعتز بها كثيرا شاب
يعتمد على نفسه بيئته في كل احتياجاته
وبيحرص على تعليم اطفال اصول العادات
والتقاليد منذ نعومه اظافرا الزواج هو اهم
العلاقات المقدسه داخل المجتمعتي دونك
عشان كده
بتنتهيئه الفتيات والصبيان منذ الصغر لهذه
المرحله وتاهيل من الدخول اليها بامان
المجتمع حريص على عكس الصوره مستقره
مثاليه عن الاسره اما بالنسبه للخلافات
والمشكلات ف العوده فيها للبدل حكام
القبيله او كبار للفصل فيها وقرار بيسري
على الجميع بدون نقاش او رفض لانه كبار
السن بيحضوا باحترام وتقدير نظرا لخبراتهم
الحياتيه ولانهم من يحملون التاريخ
والعادات والتقاليد للاجيال الجديده
التمرد على الحياه الزوجيه من الكوارث غير
المغفره داخل هذا المجتمع ومن لا يتحمل
مسؤوليه الاسره بيتم التعامل معه على انه
شخص منبوذ داخل المجتمع ومن لا يخوض
التجربه من الاساس بيتم عزلوا عن مناسبات
المجتمع العامه او التعامل معاهم على انهم
غير طبيعيين يعني علاقات الزواج المستقره
شرط من شروط القبول داخل المجتمع
والاندماج فيه او الاعتراف بكيان الشخص
كشخص طبيعي يمكن التعامل معه واحترام داخل
مجتمع قبيله تدان المجتمع بيحرص ايضا على
الاحتفال بمناسبات مختلفه خاصه على ضوء
القمر اللي بيتفائلوا به كثيرا او تقام
المناسبات دي على شرف مادبا الطعام ضخمه
بتتشارك النساء في اعداده وبيتم فيها
اداره اقساط شعبيه واغنيات محليه مختلفه
وبيعيش الكل في اجواء مرح واحتفالات في
هذه المناسبات وده تقديرا واحتراما
لكل المناسبات التقليديه اللي هم بيعترفوا
بها كبار السن عندهم تقدير خاص ومكانه
مختلفه نظرا لخبرتهم الحياتيه وبتكون
عندهم جلسات ارشاديه للنصح للاجيال
الجديده خاصه
للمقبلين على الزواج ومن ينتقلون من مرحله
لاخرى كالصبي عندما ينتقل الى مرحله
البلوغ وكذلك الفتيات
مشكلات كبيره بتحصل يتم الفصل فيها
مجتمعيا من العار الرجوع الى السلطات لحل
المشكلات لان المجتمع ده فقط لا يحب
التدخل في حياته وينغلق على عالم دون
السماح لسلطات المناطق المجاوره بان
يكونوا جزء من او يفرضوا قانون عليهم حياه
بسيطه ومسالمه الاسره فيها هي الاساس
لحياه مستقره وعادات وتقاليد رغم اختلافه
الا انه هي مصدر تمييز لهذه القبيله
الاندونيسيه المختلفه وبساطه لان هذه هي
حياته
[موسيقى]